are there any societies where there is
no right of passage where men remain
in that state of dependency on the
mother where they stay animals
well we have not many sociological
matriarchies but i read once a book
about the
south american indian tribe where there
was a actually sociological not
religious but sociological matriarchy
and there the women were happy
fat [ __ ] ordering the men about
and the men were lean submissive
nervous creatures who were
planting the fields and doing the work
for the women
kind of porter's figures
and
positively
wealth the the the world of the drives
sexuality earthly happiness
was blossoming and negatively there was
no spirit whatsoever
a world of total stupidity so to speak
of only living living very agreeably but
but not thinking or having any ideas or
spiritual realizations at all
and the men accordingly unhappy
and submissive and rather poor creatures
but generally these things balance back
and forth
there will be another generation of men
who will in male protest again
put the things into a middle position or
try to put the things in the middle
position
it seems to be the idealist seems to be
not that either the men
dominate or the women dominate but there
is a kind of
equal relationship a balance of
opposites